what's up Paul Wesley
I'm Greg Alva and I'm John Humphrey Paul
Leslie is in this trailer he's a friend
of Jason Dolan's Vampire Diaries
Jason Dolan has requested this video one
of our reward tiers at patreon is
whatever video you request we must
definitely put up on YouTube even if we
hate your requests yeah we must do it
nine times out of ten the requests we
hate most videos we most videos we watch
we are only pretending to enjoy it
actually Jason Dolan this is not the
camera we are using but he recently got
us a mazing gift is a brand-new camera
because the camera were recording on
it's constantly having problems the
reason we're not using that camera right
now is because we want to get an extra
battery because we do a lot of stack
shooting most days we don't want to just
keep stopping and charging up one
battery but Jason I wanted to thank you
here on the youtubes very much so you
are the bomb my friend you're the bomb
keep a lookout for his upcoming film
he's working on blood loss and also yeah
patreon I unboxed the the the camera he
got us and that crying man started
crying and roll that footage mr. Jason
Dolan did you um did you send us a
camera Hey every gift we ever get is
always an emotional experience but this
one especially because man when you feel
like you got no camera you're like I
can't afford anything without I can't
work keeping the funny going oh yeah do
those cheap funny dude every time you
cry on this channel this is comedy gold
remember that one okay
[Music]
but the world is no question that that
guy bad bets Kevin Williams 71 scream
hey what's going on with you trouble but
sometimes a wolf gets separated from
this
okay beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
yes tiny Fred the universe is a cosmic
hell
it's like a like a semi horror crime
anthology or is it gonna be like the
same characters in a world where
fairytale esque things keep happening
John let me tell you what I know what I
could tell you what this is about
alright let's do it I don't know what
those three little pigs Rob banking and
there you go
okay so according to amoeba the world's
most beloved fairy tales are reimagined
as a dark and twisted psychological
thriller set in modern-day
New York City the first season of the
serialize drama in her leaves the three
little pigs
hence the people pulling the heist with
the pig mask that I understand Jack and
the Beanstalk that's what that giant
character was yeah when they climb up
into the clouds and all the rioting yeah
this guy totally okay I get it now I get
into an epic and subversive tale of love
lost greed revenge and murder okay
now in this little description of love
lost Gruber Benja more that's all very
present it seems like the hook according
to the first couple lines of this IMDB
plot summary is the idea you're taking
classic fairy tale stories and you're
turning it into modern-day drama which
is exactly what I would like seems like
it's probably gonna borrow the themes
and the messages of those stories
perhaps and maybe some of the
iconography a lot more than the literal
after looking at the description you do
see some of that Red Riding Hood stuff
in there with the grandma with the red
coat and she's even going up the
escalator with her hoodie on and there
are little allusions to wolves and teeth
and things like that yeah I don't really
get I mean there are people climbing
stairs and stuff and there's a guy in
like a little green looking dance belt
or so yeah there's not much I caught
from the Jack and the Beanstalk story
I'll be honest I'm a liar this pitch
that I'm reading of the description
entices me a lot more than the act
little trailer did itself the trailer
itself to me kind of just look like
generic traumatic images I can't see
past the CBS element I'm like it's not
gonna go that great great someone was
doing cocaine in here which was a little
surprising to me I would like to see
more of what they're talking about here
of interweaving three little pigs a
little red riding-hood Jack and the
Beanstalk that hook is not so present
here in the trailer and it's all tell me
a story so I would like we're allowed to
be present granted I haven't seen any
episodes but it seems like maybe the
concept of this show might be a little
hard to get across in a
minute-and-a-half trailer you know you
got so much to draw from over a season
and I kind of fall in the middle because
part of me goes yeah I'm super spoiled
by cable TV where I know that they're
not gonna pull punches but at the same
time I mean I've heard a lot of great
things about the following and that was
one of their darker more heavy shows
kind of like a Hannibal almost and you
know even Hannibal got away on network
with a lot of gore and a lot of thematic
elements that are a bit more extreme so
I don't think it's impossible for
something like this no I agree at the
same time though I'm like what's the
linear storyline here the guy's a
showrunner of this has written a lot of
great horror and a lot of great TV shows
he wrote the first two screen movies he
wrote the faculty which I really enjoy
and we're talking 20 of TV shows that
were listed even in this trailer so I
imagine this would probably be an
effective and good TV show it's very
hard to imagine that it wouldn't be I'm
strictly judging the trailer not the
show oh yeah of course and I mean Kevin
Williamson seems like he's good at
breaking stuff like this down and
translating or transposing elements of
the fairy tales like into something like
scream is very meta and deconstructive
and aware of the genres that its
borrowing from and so I can see him
applying that sensibility here to these
fairy tales or whatever and you know
fairy tale Network TV is kind of a trend
right now cuz you got things like grim
and you had things like Once Upon a Time
or whatever so I mean it doesn't look
really like those shows looks like a lot
more grounded than those shows I just I
can't help but feel that if this was on
cable this would probably look a lot
more appealing because they're dealing
with crime there's a lot of sex there's
drugs there's violence and that's all
gonna kind of
reach a certain limit on a network
television show in my personal opinion
for sure although good writing can make
up for just about anything can it yes
can it yes okay I'm gonna fight you on
that I mean you're probably right not
great Bob I mean you got a couple of
guys here who are like having sex with
each other at one point which is
straight out of hands on the gret on
this girl's I'm buckling this one guy's
pants you know it's not gonna get so far
on CBS there's gonna be so much I'm
wondering is this world some type of
alternate reality or is this taking
place in our modern day times it seems
like the world that are living in is not
a good world there's a lot of civil
unrest and a lot of seedy yes it looks
like New York is falling apart here and
these characters are taking paths that
are ultimately in them down insanely
darker paths which is usually a story
I'm very much drawn to if anything it
seems like it's very loosely inspired by
these fairy tales yeah and I guess when
I read that pitch I'm like I want as
literal inspired those taking the themes
the little nods here and there yeah and
I mean the most obvious iconography is
the pigs is the pigs but even the little
red riding-hood one if you like look out
for it you can see yeah you know yeah
and I mean I wonder if those two stories
will cross at least because both of
those involve a wolf of some kind
whoever or whatever that presence or
character winds up being I just wanted a
fairytale cinematic universe on CBS
that's exactly you're already got it and
you got hellas seasons to catch up on
now one point there are two characters
in the pool which I'm assuming is
borrowing from the little mermaid fairy
tale yeah that guy Sebastian you're not
reaching here at all or this is all this
is what you call trailer breakdown hit
swipe unless we call expertise I mean it
looks intriguing I don't have
regular television so unless this goes
some Netflix I probably won't check it
out but in terms of knowing who's behind
it and knowing what this storyline is I
am it I'm very much intrigued by it I
would probably check out like the first
four episodes if I have access to it to
see if it's yeah I would watch I mean I
watch a ton of Network stuff but this is
certainly something in the vein I would
check out give give yeah yeah and
especially like knowing it's coming from
Kevin Williamson
I've liked a number of things that he's
done and I've also heard some great
things about a few of his darker TV
shows it's just who's the audience it's
for is my question because if you're
gonna pitch it with you know the twist
on these classic fairy tales but what
are the dark modern-day setting but it
seems like it's so subtle yeah really
grounded seems like the audience who
likes those stories for like Once Upon a
Time or something they probably
gravitated towards that but is that kind
of crowd the kind of crowd who would
watch this show too so if it's so subtle
and not so in-your-face about it cuz I
feel like it was more anger face about
it the audience to be a lot more clear
on who it's for
kind of like what bright was or rim like
he was very much fantastical even yeah
so a cop procedure yeah because there's
no fantastical element here yeah the
most fantastical thing is like pig masks
yeah yeah I wonder I mean I get the
sense that if you're just a fan of crime
shows in general that's an easy market
to get at and imagine like fans of Grimm
might be enticed into this not as much
fans of Once Upon a Time actually
because that shows a lot more whimsical
and melodramatic and it's just not like
but maybe I'll carve a new niche out
didn't Lucifer do well that was kind of
yeah but it was still uh there's still a
fantastical element to it true that yeah
you know he's the devil yeah you know
Jason clear this up for her this up
Jason are gonna leave a freaking
monologue of a comment so do it
love you I like you a lot
I'm fond of you I can tolerate you I can
take her leave you I wish you would fall
off a cliff I'm going to kill you
hello rejects well you can subscribe to
the reject nation where we clearly know
everything and you could check us out on
patreon oh because there's [ __ ] there
and you can also you know click the
notification bell for channels like
Screen Rant take care bye bye